I just thought I'd touch base if you're
on the phone really just to check that
you're both okay and and then you've got
a lot on your plate we've been pregnancy
and being in isolation and stuff so the
last thing I wanted was you to feel
nervous or stressed out you know as a
tenant with all what's going on I think
that's the plan I don't think we're
probably gonna ever sell it to be honest
I mean we've just been talking and since
speaking to you I think it's probably
it's probably better that we just keep
it I mean what's your kind of long-term
plan because you were talking about
decorating it for your baby and
everything right are you do you really
like living there yeah six years and
you've never paid like you've been
fantastic tenants so we were just
thinking about it we thought oh man
should we you know should we maybe just
just just just not sell it so yeah I
think we're probably gonna ever sell it
to be honest I mean we've just been
talking and since speaking to you which
would you would you ever consider buying
the house what's your long-term plan do
you ever plan on buying a house have you
ever heard of being a tenant buyer yeah
why don't you look why don't you look
into rent to buy look into it google it
because if you if you if you wanted to
do a rent to buy top arrangement with us
where you could continue being a tenant
continue paying rent but work your way
up to buying it and have like an option
to buy it so that that way you've got
complete peace of mind knowing that it's
basically your house I mean look into it
and if you want to make us an offer on a
rent to buy basis I mean we'd be very
open we'd be very open to do that as
well I mean I'd be very very happy to do
something like that and I'd also be
happy to just keep you in to tenant but
I think yeah I mean we've got another
property just down the road from you
it's the exact same story they've been
in there like five years and we've
decided not to sell that one other
because the tenants are just so nice and
they're so good we just we just thought
let's not so I'm going to speak to them
about the rent of my idea yeah Google it
and then message Amanda but all the way
you know nothing's gonna happen until
September time anyway so go ahead and
decorate your room do what you need to
do and we'll we'll keep you completely
posted not today
you know if like if down the line next
year whatever we if we consider selling
again well always let you know but I
just don't think it's a good time for us
to sell and I don't think it's
definitely not good time for you if
you're about to have a baby and we're in
isolation so definitely this year you
know selling is off the table
no that's fine oh I'll speak to you soon
bye
I look I love I love good tenants you
forget sometime that this is actually
people's like homes and then you've got
a property from you it's a property
investment especially someone's home and
I think it's hard like this in lockdown
isolation when you realize that because
when do we normally speak to my tenants
we just have managers and there's no but
as now everything's just changed we just
figured we've got Tom and I hands we
might as well we catch some of the
tenants and to the end on its it's
really quite interesting and some of the
houses that we're gonna sell and to be
fair that house I look selfishly it
wouldn't be a good time to sell it now
because we'd have to take we'd have to
take a hit and we were like oh no way we
poured it from the auction because we
just built probably gonna get a low
offer
we've got lovely talents in there but
I'm really glad we did I definitely
don't
to sell any time soon good tenants look
after you tenant speak to your tenants
remember that they're ultimately your
customers we talk about financial
freedom and having a passive income but
actually it's it's people like like that
enable us to live our lives so send some
love details if you're a landlord send
some love you tell us today send them a
nice nice note maybe pick up the phone
and call them and just check you know
how they're doing that's my that's my
homework for you guys today